[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
from the beginning of civilization we've
known there was something captivating
about watching human beings fight for
their lives
that's why we watched gladiator games
public executions
we created a sport for people who still
have a thirst for savagery what did you
just do our customers are some of the
most powerful people in the world
a real fun game
every year they demand more
more complicated rooms more ways to
gamble on life and death and we provided
them with
a boxing for life's ultimate drama
this serves as an entry value for
amino's escape rooms are there rules and
regulations or what you just have to
escape before the clock runs out
anything that looks like a puzzle or a
code numbers are very important it could
be anything anywhere
sorry you go first they're watching us
they know every move that we're making
they do everything about us
[Music]
she sacrificed herself for us
you're the psycho that designed this
murder maze huh no i'm the game's master
the puzzle maker designs the room
everyone else who sent those invitations
died and whoever sent them is still out
there the logo their coordinates in the
middle of manhattan are you in
yeah i'm
tell in what you see
every time i close my eyes i see them
fall
[Music]
i still hear their screams see their
faces
what else do you remember
i remember that
in the middle of everything
amanda
took the time to hold my hand to tell me
that
everything was gonna be okay
your mother's not
really gone though
be more specific
i
told her about my fear of flying
i told her about my mother the plane
crash
and what did she say
i have a daughter
she
told me about her daughter and how she
kept her clothes when she was deployed
overseas
wanted to be sure that she'd always be
with me
i told her
when someone you love
becomes a memory
that memory becomes a treasure
it sounds like amanda was a good friend
she was
beminos killed her
minos killed all of them
ah you don't believe me
zoe
i'm only trying to help you
how can you help me if you don't believe
me
you think i'm insane
i'm only trying to communicate to you
that to a hammer
everything is a nail what what is that
supposed to mean it means your truth is
your truth
but right now you're so deep inside the
game world that every single thing you
see is a clue
this
is a clue
uh
this is a clue
this is a clue
everything you see reinforces your
existing beliefs
so that you're caught in an endless loop
the game is all there is and all there
is is the game
sorry our time is up
look
zoe my job isn't to believe you
my job is to make you better
so let me ask you
what would it take for you to be free
from this
what would it take
yes take that trip to new york you keep
talking about the one with ben that you
keep postponing you've tried to fly
three times you can't do this yeah okay
let's go no no hey zoe
yeah i wanted to run that by you
actually
we're thinking of uh driving there what
would it take to finally get you on that
plane
because that's what we want isn't it zoe
to get you on that plane
i need to know that the criminals who
killed the four people in front of me
were held accountable for what they did
and i need to know
that they're never going to do it again
to me or to anyone else
then
and only then will this all be over
hey ben
hey hey
what'd you say
she thinks that driving to new york is a
way of avoiding my underlying fear of
flying
you know me the best way to get me to do
something is tell me not to do it
what does that mean
let's do it
let's drive
but there have been trucks going in and
out of that building for three days
they wouldn't embed their coordinates
into the company logo if didn't mean
something
i think you were gonna fly with me it's
just these past few weeks i've kind of
really
really enjoyed
not dying
would you stop if we get lucky we can
take some photos
it'll be more evidence than we have now
which is nothing
okay yeah
sure you don't want to stop in cleveland
ben i said no detours
i know this is a lot to ask so thank you
for coming with me well i have this uh
weird loyalty thing for people who save
my life
thanks
well
don't think me too much
i don't have any gas money
actually don't have any money
no
i'm not spending the next two days in a
car full of smoke with you
should we go to bed
are you tired
no but
you should try right
yeah
up yo go ahead no no you go yeah you you
said it first no no no no no no no go go
go ahead
smoothness
come on
oh
i think you just had a nightmare
i was sorry my son
the whole thing was just
just a dream
we gotta get these guys yeah
yeah let's get out of here
we're almost there
it's an old abandoned government
building there's no record there's no
deed it's a total black hole
[Music]
you